so we have a nice little equation here
that has some rational expressions in it
and and like always pause the video and
and see if you can figure out which x's
satisfy this equation
all right let's work through it together
now when i see things in the denominator
like this my instinct is to try to not
have denominators like this and so what
we could do is to get rid of this x
minus 1 and the denominator on the
left-hand side we can multiply both
sides of the equation times x minus 1
x minus 1. so we're going to multiply
both sides
by
x minus 1. and once again the whole
point of doing that is so that we get
rid of this x minus 1 in the denominator
right over here
and then since to get rid of this x plus
1 in the denominator over here we can
multiply both sides of the equation
times x plus 1.
so
x plus 1
multiply both sides times x plus 1. and
so what is that going to give us
well on
the left hand side that is going to x
minus 1 divided by x minus 1 is just
going to be 1
for the x's where
for for the x's where that's defined for
x naught being equal to 1. and so we're
going to have x plus 1 times negative 2x
plus 4. so let me write that down so we
have x plus i think i'm going to need
some space so let me make sure i don't
write too big x plus 1
times
negative 2x negative 2x
plus 4
is going to be equal to
now if we multiply both of these times 3
over x plus 1 the x plus 1 is going to
cancel with the x plus 1 and we're going
to be left with 3 times x minus 1.
so that is going to be 3x minus 3 3x
minus 3
and then
minus
1 times both of these so 1 times x minus
1 times x plus 1.
so minus 1 times x minus 1 times x plus
1. all i did is i multiplied took the x
minus 1 times x plus 1 multiplied times
each of these terms when i multiplied it
times this first term the x plus 1 and
the x plus 1 canceled so i just have to
multiply 3 times x minus 1. and then for
the second term i just multiplied it
times both of these and now you might
recognize this if you have something x
plus 1 times x minus 1 that's going to
be x squared minus 1. so i could rewrite
all of this right over here as being
equal to
as being equal to
x squared minus 1 and once again that's
because this
is the same thing as x squared minus 1.
and since i'm subtracting an x squared
minus 1. actually let me just i don't
want to do too much in on one step so
let's go to the next step so i could
multiply this out so i could multiply
x times
negative 2x which would give us negative
2x squared
x times
4 which is going to give us plus 4x and
i can multiply 1 times negative 2x so
i'm going to subtract 2x and then 1
times 4 which is going to be plus 4
and then that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to
we have
x minus 3 and then we can distribute
this negative sign so we could say minus
x squared plus 1.
and over here we can simplify it a
little bit
this is going to be
that is 4x minus 2x is going to be
let me make sure i didn't write over yep
4x minus 2x so that would be 2x
and so this is simplified to
let's see well this is we have a
negative three and a one so those two
together are going to be equal to
subtracting a two
so we can rewrite everything as i'll do
a neutral color now
negative two x squared plus two x
plus four
is equal to
negative x squared
plus three x
plus three x minus two
now we can try to get all of this
business on to the right hand side so
let's subtract it from both sides so
we're going to subtract
so we'll add x squared to both sides
add x squared that gets rid of this
white x this white negative x squared
we subtract 3x from both sides subtract
3x from both sides
add 2 to both sides add 2 and we will be
left with
we are going to end up with
see negative 2x squared plus x squared
is negative x squared 2x minus 3x is
negative x and then 4 plus 2 is
is going to be equal to well that's
going to cancel with that that that
is equal to 0. i don't like having this
negative on the x squared so let's
multiply both sides times negative 1.
and so if i do that so
if i just take the negative of both
sides
so if i just multiply that times
negative 1. same thing as taking the
negative both sides i'm going to get
knit i'm going to get positive x squared
plus x
minus 6 is equal to 0 and we're making
some good progress here so we can factor
this and actually let me just do it
right over here so that we can see the
original problem
so
if i were to factor this what two
numbers their product is negative six
they're going to have different signs
since their product is negative and they
add up to 1 the coefficient on the first
degree term
well positive 3 and negative 2 work so i
can rewrite this as
x plus 3
times x minus 2
is equal to
zero did i do that right yeah three
times negative two is negative six three
x minus two x is positive x
all right so i just factored i just
wrote this in this quadratic in factored
form and so the way that you get this
equaling 0 is if either one of those
equals 0 x plus 3
equals 0
or
x minus 2 is equal to 0. well this is
going to happen if you subtract 3 from
both sides you get that's going to
happen if x is equal to negative 3
or over here if you add 2 to both sides
x is equal to 2.
so either one of these will satisfy but
we want to be careful we want to make
sure that our original equation isn't
going to be undefined for either one of
these and negative 3 does not make
either of the denominators equal to 0 so
that's cool and positive 2 does not make
either of the denominators equal to 0.
so it looks like we're in good shape
there's two solutions
two
to that equation if one of them made the
denom either any of the denominators
equal to zero then they wouldn't have
then they would have been extraneous
solutions it would have been solutions
for some of our intermediate steps but
not for the actual original equations
with the expressions as they were
written but this we can feel good about
because neither of these make any of
these denominators equal to 0.